area this clip was taken by Filipinos
held at a Cambodian police station in
January they say it shows they were
victims of human trafficking
two of the group have since returned
home and told Al Jazeera their
experiences were horrific Bruno doesn't
want to reveal his identity and says he
was made to travel from one country to
another illegally and by boat
there were 17 of us in a small wooden
boat including an infant and Luggage
that was the most traumatic part because
the boat took up size anytime and no one
would find out if we died
this was their destination in Cambodia a
large business complex with many
buildings miles says there were given
customer service jobs but then forced to
carry out online fraud
the third day of chatting is when we
offer potential victims fake crypto
Investments the lowest offer is fifty
dollars but it can go up to as much as
fifty thousand dollars
but unlike Bruno miles was flown to
Cambodia posing as a tourist what are
the more common routes and methods
according to victims
Filipino trafficking victims who've come
forward say they're usually questioned
at border checks when leaving the
Philippines but they passed through with
relative ease they say at least one
immigration officer stamped their
passports and let them straight through
at least six officers are being
investigated by the Bureau of
immigration or bi following Senate
inquiries
the bi should not be a scene of the
crime it should be the last line of
defense for our migrant workers so it
really has to crack down on The
Syndicate or Syndicate still operating
within human trafficking during the
legislative hearings it was also
revealed that the government had rescued
200 victims caught in a similar scheme
they were not only from Cambodia but
Laos and Myanmar
that's raised fears many more crimes
like these are going undetected
below Al Jazeera Manila